Every level of trader explained. Level
one, the gambler. These are the guys
that come into the stock market thinking
they will get rich quick off of a Reddit
comment. You ever heard of Wall Street
Bets? They think they are in the movie
The Wolf of Wall Street.
>> Come on.
>> But in reality, they are no different
than any gambling addict out there.
>> Scrape it. Scrape it.
>> Outstanding. Every one of them gets
baited by one person a 100 timesing
their money. They'll see a person who
makes a post called a DD where they will
write a whole essay on why they think a
company or a certain trade will be
really really good. This will cause a
ton of people to blindly follow and bet
a huge amount of money on the direction
that that one person off the internet
said that they think the stock will go.
When things go badly, they will diamond
hands the trade, meaning they won't sell
because they think eventually, no matter
what, how long they hold, it will work
out in their favor. Another crazy thing
that these people do is they will get
access to high lever trading assets like
options where they will bet something
like, let's say, $50,000 on a trade and
if it doesn't work out within a couple
of days, they lose all their money. And
sometimes they'll lose more than their
account value. These guys will diamond
hands until they owe money. It's
incredible. All for the chance that they
will get rich quick. In reality, they
are just gambling, but it's disguised as
having knowledge. But it's no different
than putting your life savings in a slot
machine. Level two, the chart god. You
know the Dunning Kruger effect. When you
start learning about something, you get
to a point in that process where you
think you know everything, but in
reality, it's just the tip of the
iceberg. That's called Mount Stupid. And
that's where these guys are. These guys
have dove into the unlimited amounts of
information there is out there on the
stock market. earnings reports, books,
fundamental analysis, technical
analysis, charts, using every indicator
possible to perfectly map exactly what
the is going to happen and what is going
to happen in the market. Thinking the
more they add and the more knowledge
they consume will increase their win
rate. They use every strategy possible
trading every type of asset they can,
crypto, forex, stocks, options. They
know that they can master the market.
They just need one more trading pattern,
but when it actually comes to trading,
they aren't doing anything consistent.
They're all over the place, which just
ends up losing all their money. They
haven't realized that learning more
about the market doesn't actually
increase their win rate because in
reality, you can never figure out the
market because there's unlimited
potential outcomes with unlimited amount
of information out there. Level three,
the grasshopper. This is where most
people that start trying to trade
eventually give up. They realize trading
is actually really hard and takes an
insane amount of work. They aren't going
to have money flowing out of their ears
anytime soon. jumping from strategy to
strategy. They get stuck in this losing
dopamine cycle of trying a strategy,
blowing up their account, and then
having a YouTube video pop up on their
home screen with another new amazing
strategy. They watch it and think, "Wow,
this time I will make it work." But end
up blowing another account. Somewhere in
the cycle, most people hit that wall of
failing so much they actually can't take
it anymore and give up. They think the
strategy doesn't work and they don't
realize it's not the strategy that
doesn't work, but they're failure to
consistently execute the strategy. They
are still chasing the Lambo at the end
of the rainbow. They lack the discipline
to consistently stick to one strategy.
After a week or two of it not working,
they give up and move on to the new
strategy when in reality they're the
problem. Level four, the awakening.
After years of losing money, jumping
from strategy to strategy, these traders
have finally become self-aware that it's
not actually the strategy that isn't
working out. It's them. They realize
they have to change. They realize they
can't be chasing the money all the time,
but need to commit to a process of what
can they consistently do to be
profitable. Not chasing the shiny object
of a new strategy or new information,
but fall back on what they've actually
had some success with. Generally, this
means executing one strategy instead of
five. Simplifying what they are doing.
They realize they can't actually
outsmart the market, but must wait for
the market to fit their strategy to make
money. They start to put in the hard
work of changing their emotional
patterns that are negatively affecting
their ability to consistently execute
their trading strategy with discipline.
This is where taking advantage of
something like the Ninja Trader Arena
Cup Challenge is perfect. It's starting
really soon with a $400,000
prize pool. It's completely free to join
and you're trading on a demo account.
So, it's literally risk-free, but a
chance at real money. You can join via
this QR code or just using the link
below. Level five, the whipssaw trader.
These traders have started to execute
their trading strategy consistently.
They have times of success, but then
they also have times where they get
overly excited going on a win streak.
They get the feeling that they finally
made it and they'll be able to buy a
Ferrari this time next month. But this
greed overtakes them, derailing their
ability to consistently execute their
strategy. So, they give up all their
profits. This causes an emotional cycle
of focusing, going on a win streak, and
then getting too excited, thinking they
are smarter than the market. Then the
market humbles them again. Eventually
going through this cycle, they will
either give up, still never finding true
success, or they will break from the
emotional pattern and move on to the
next level. Level six, the consistent
trader. These guys have finally made it
to being consistently profitable. No
more boom and bust cycles. They don't
have crazy emotional swings, but they
have to stay really focused on sticking
to their strategy because it's easy for
them to potentially deviate from it.
They haven't fully mastered their craft,
but they now have the potential to make
a full-time income from their trading.
They just have to work through the
phases of increasing their trading size.
They know what it takes to be successful
at trading and have done it.
Level seven, the master. These guys make
unfathomable amounts of money from the
market on a consistent basis. What the
level one gamblers were trying and
thought they could do, these guys
actually do. They have ups and downs,
but they are because of normal strategy
swings, not because of their emotions.
They're able to make consistent money
over time at huge quantities, making 50
or $100,000 a month. They live whatever
life they want as money isn't an issue
anymore for them. Now, they still
understand that they have to be
extremely focused, disciplined, and
consistent with how they approach
trading and prep for every day. But they
have such muscle memory for doing it,
any ups and downs don't cause dramatic
emotional effects in their life. It just
seems like business as usual. So, what
level of trader are you? Let me know in
the comments below. And make sure to
take advantage of the $400,000 Ninja
Trader Arena Cup Challenge.